[Applaudissements]
c'est ce que vous pensez de matthieu
delormeau derrière vous êtes vous êtes
un ami à lui matthieu delormeau le match
de rugby que vous êtes un ami à lui on a
tout on a beaucoup parlé de ça où on est
potes
ouais ouais bah voila mon meilleur ami
on se connaît c'est vrai c'est votre ami
vous l'avez déjà plus je savais pas qui
c'était il ya 20 minutes une femme vient
d'accoucher
alors on lui met le bébé sur entre les
murs elle regarde elle fond en larmes
elle regarda dit quand je pense qu'il ya
neuf mois je faillite avaler ses deux
potes ils font du camping et puis à 3
heures du matin il a toqué 30 dans
l'attenté un mec il se réveille il dit à
son pote m'a tant tu fais quoi là elle
au daily beast moment-là et son pote tu
vas tu es gentil tu prends ta [ __ ]
ailleurs dans la vraie vie tu es
complètement du genre est finie quand ça
sera bon